it's kind of the best twist of all
because you're kind of thrown by it but
sometimes that happens sometimes you're
with a guy that's really great but it
just doesn't really feel right and i'm
excited i don't know what's gonna happen
season two so i'm very excited to see
and because you're excited i'm excited
and that's really exciting
pretty smart with such an easy breezy
fun binge i loved the fact that you guys
left us on a huge cliffhanger we ended
season one of pretty smart with claire
kissing grant moments before chelsea was
about to say that grant and her want to
start dating total drama i'm so here for
it what was your reaction to this love
triangle twist emily break it down oh
yeah i mean i remember reading that and
and being like audibly upset
do this to us you know you kind of see
it coming and this is such a nice twist
that you kind of don't expect from
claire and especially because we have
kevin miles who's so so lovely on the
show and is such an excellent guy you
love them together they make perfect
sense they're just such a good match and
then out of nowhere i mean it's kind of
the best twist of all because you're
kind of thrown by it but sometimes that
happens sometimes you're with a guy
that's really great but it just doesn't
really feel right and i'm excited i
don't know what's gonna happen season
two so i'm very excited to see at first
i was very upset but the truth is i look
at my life in my twenties whether it was
myself or my friends and who hasn't made
the wrong decision that's the point
you're so
i don't know if it's necessarily the
wrong decision but you have to do that
to learn you have to figure it out she's
a 20-something woman she's not likely to
end up with the guy that she's dating
right now and i think it's better that
she navigates what love means for her
what relationships mean for her this is
grant we used to date but we had a
mutual breakup so now we're rooming how
french actually nebraska
nebraska usa
i think my reaction when i first read
the script was the reaction that you see
in the take confusion
uh more of like oh
[Music]
basically i don't know
what's about to happen so uh this is
about to get interesting was uh it was
my feeling maybe i like living with
these people
hit me
well i've got to put the roomies on the
spot here right now because i'm so torn
for who would be a good fit for grant
we've barely seen his relationship with
claire we've seen the slow burn with
chelsea greg how are you feeling who
would you like to see be together in
season two it's so tough i really don't
know i don't know because i think that
there's a real lovely
innocence between grant and claire and
on the flip side i think there's a real
sort of evolution and growth with grant
and chelsea and the chelsea's taught
grant so much and grant's now becoming a
more educated human being which he needs
so yeah i don't know i mean both of them
both olivia and emily are so great to
work with and so however the writers
take it i'll be happy with either but
yeah a great great great potential love
triangle uh that is being formed you
talk like a troll guarding a bridge
i think i might be a little more team
chelsea just because i love growth i
love when people change and and get a
little bit more open-minded and i think
that the two of them it's sort of
unlikely pair but they have such a nice
little bond well i mean it's in the
cards for grant and chelsea so that's
definitely who i'd be rooting for also
it's a little drama is fun so i'm
definitely more into this love triangle
gotcha [ __ ] i think claire and grant
are similar in ways that they think and
sometimes i can go stale and i think
sometimes opposites attract in that way
but maybe there's a new character we can
throw in the mix i don't know trying to
push season two man let's do it let's
throw them all in there let's see who
works the best we'll do a dating game
with greg the opposition between grant
and chelsea is so interesting
and in my mind i'm like what would that
be like and i think other people will be
too and let's see it let's see what
happens when these two complete
opposites get together wow you know
you're actually inspiring me to work out
no to have ice cream
if there is a pretty smart season too
and there's a live audience are you
still open to all those shirt listings
well we've got to you know we've got to
make sure that there's healthy food on
on set those days because you know it's
tough taking your shirt off a lot you
got to stay disciplined so don't feel
too bad for him one time greg described
his favorite food as celery because uh
he eats for the chew yeah it's just for
the true it's not really for the taste
those were his back words
to watch greg work so hard for all the
shirtless scenes i mean i have never
worked with an actor that was more
committed right it was like hats off to
greg with two g's because you killed it
i tried to work out with him like twice
and that was it
one more it's gonna take a while for us
to figure this out
you